- [Voiceover] So let's do
another curvature example.
This time, I'll just take
a two-dimensional curve,
so it'll have two different
components, x of t and y of t
and the specific components here will be
t minus the sine of t,
t minus sine of t,
and then one minus cosine of t.
One minus cosine of t.
This is actually the curve,
if you watched the very
first video that I did
about curvature introducing
it, this is that curve.
This is the curve that I said,
"Imagine that it's a
road and you're driving
"along it, and if your
steering wheel gets stuck,
"you're thinking of the
circle that you trace out
"as a result and it
various different points
"you're gonna be turning it
various different amounts,"
so the circle that your
car ends up tracing out
would be of varying sizes.
So if the curvature's high,
if you're steering a lot,
radius of curvature is
low and things like that.
So here, let's actually compute it.
And in the last example I walked through
thinking in terms of the derivative
of the unit-tangent vector
with respect to arc length
but in this case, instead of doing that,
I just want to show what it looks like
when we take the explicit
formula that looks like
x prime times y double-prime,
minus y prime times x double-prime,
and then all of that divided by
x prime squared plus y prime squared.
And then I'm writing x
prime and y prime and such
and all of these you should think of as
taking in the variable t.
I'm must being a little
too lazy to write it.
And you take that to
the three-halves power.
So, this was the formula
and I'm not a huge fan
of memorizing formulas
and then hoping to apply them later.
I really do think the one
thing you should take away
from curvature is the idea that
it's the derivative of
the unit-tangent vector
with respect to arc length
and if you need to, you can just look up
a formula like this but
it's worth pointing out
that it makes some things easier
to compute because
finding the tangent vector
and everything can be
kind of like reinventing
the wheel when you already
have the results here.
So, first thing to do is just find
x prime, y double-prime,
y prime and x double prime.
So let's go ahead and write those out.
So the first derivative of x of t
if we go up here that's t minus sine of t.
So its derivative is
one minus cosine of t.
And the derivative of the y component
of one minus cosine t,
y prime of t,
is gonna be, derivative
of cosine is negative sine
so negative derivative of that is sine,
and that one goes to a constant,
and then when we take the second
derivatives of those guys,
so maybe change the color for
the second derivative here,
x double prime of the,
so now we're taking
the derivative of this,
which actually we just did because
by coincidence the first derivative of x
is also the y component
so that also equals sine of t.
And then y double prime is just
the derivative of sine here
so that's just gonna
be cosine, cosine of t.
So now, when we just
plug those four values
in for kappa, for our
curvature, what we get
is x prime was one minus cosine of t,
multiplied by y double
prime is cosine of t.
Cosine of t.
We subtract off from that y prime,
which is sine of t,
sine of t,
multiplied by x double prime.
So x double prime is also sine of t,
so I could just say
sine of t squared,
and the whole thing is
divided by x prime squared
so x prime was one minus cosine of t,
minus cosine of t,
squared, plus y prime squared
so y prime was just sine,
so that's just gonna be sine squared of t.
And that whole thing to
the power three halves.
And that's your answer, right?
You apply the formula, you get the answer.
So for example, when I
was drawing this curve
and kind of telling the
computer to draw out
the appropriate circle,
I didn't go through
the entire "find the unit tangent vector,
"differentiate it with respect
with arc length" process,
even though that's decently easy to do
in the case of things
like circles or helixes
but instead I just went to that formula.
I looked it up because I had forgotten
and I found the radius
of curvature that way.